[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de votre
fidélité à dimanche en politique sur
france 3 bourgogne depuis la déroute de
françois fillon à l'élection
présidentielle et la victoire d'emmanuel
macron la droite est dans tous ses états
entre les courants historiques et les
plus récents la droite française n'a
sans doute jamais autant été divisé la
droite macro nist celles qu'on retrouve
au gouvernement notamment la droite
constructive pro macron désormais exclu
du parti des républicains est unie au
centre droit de l'ue dei
il y a les républicains modérés incarné
par xavier bertrand ou valérie pécresse
par exemple et enfin on retrouve la
droite décomplexée plutôt sarkozyste
parfois fillonniste emmenée par laurent
wauquiez à la droite de la droite debout
la france où les patriotes de florent
reliant philippot espère jouer un rôle
dans cette recomposition politique tout
comme d'ailleurs certains membres du
front national alors quelle place pour
la droite entre le pen et macron quelle
ligne adoptée pour exister face à la
république en marche
et quel leader pour la droite demain on
en débat ce dimanche dans dimanche en
politique en direct sur france 3 avec
nos invités gilles platret bonjour
bonjour vous êtes maire les républicains
de chalon sur saône et porte parole de
laurent wauquiez dans la campagne
interne à la présidence des républicains
merci d'être avec nous clarisse quand on
joue
vous êtes adjointe au maire de sens
conseillère départementale les
républicains de l'yonne est proche de
valérie pécresse un autre courant au
sein des républicains merci d'être
également avec nous maxime thiébaut
bonjour vous êtes co fondateur du
mouvement les républiques les patriotes
par d'autres on va y arriver
les patriots avec un parcours
particulier puisque vous venez de debout
la france passait très furtivement par
le front national est aujourd'hui proche
de florian philippot pascal grappin
bonjour bonjour vous êtes maire de
villebichot conseiller régional et
président de l'udps et en côte-d'or
tendance nouveau centre constructive
quand même plus ou moins on en parlera
dans ce truc qui influe lui dit
effectivement
a rejoint du moins les députés à
l'assemblée nationale
u10 ont rejoint le mouvement constructif
mais il y a il y à débat chez nous on va
en parler dans un instant merci à tous
les cadres d'avoir accepté de participer
à cette émission vous pouvez bien sûr
vous qui la regarde et commentée sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag est dit
mme paul bourgogne alors je vous propose
de débuter par ces images c'était jeudi
à colombey les deux églises avec un
défilé de politiques sur la tombe du
général de gaulle 47 ans après sa mort
laurent wauquiez la maire socialiste de
paris anne hidalgo
florian philippot nicolas dupont aignan
et tant d'autres ils sont venues de tous
bords
au moment où la droite est en morceaux
qu'en dirait le général gilles platret
je sais pas et peut-être qu'ils se
rappelleraient cette parole de malraux
le gaullisme c'est le métro à six heures
du soir tout le monde a été est ou sera
gaulliste aujourd'hui je pense que la
référence au général de gaulle notamment
lorsqu'elle est récupéré par ceux dont
l'idéologie souhaitait plutôt sa mort
avant le terme dans les années 60 est un
petit peu risible mais elle est aussi le
signe de ce que dans un pays qui va pas
bien on se réfère à ce qui semble encore
être un passé pas si lointain d'ailleurs
mais qui fonctionnait bien donc je pense
qu'il ya une véritable psychologie du
gaullisme bon après chacun trouvera ses
petits chacun a son interprétation c'est
mme eliane attendu après charles de
gaulle appartient à l'histoire il
n'appartient pas à un parti politique
donc ça c'est important de le rappeler
mais je pense qu'il ya des partis
politiques qui cultivent plus son
héritage que d'autres car il cependant
il serait déçu le général de gaulle de
voir cette droite plus divisé que jamais
je disais au début de cette émission je
ne sais pas s'il très déçu c'est sûr
qu'on est on est un vrai tournant qu'il
faut qu'il faut repenser qu'il faut
repenser un peu la droite et et que tout
le monde se rappelle se souviennent du
général de gaulle en ce moment c'est
parce qu'on cherche aussi une une base
solide pour pour reconstruire le
mouvement le général de gaulle c'était
un chef aussi c'était un leader
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ce dont vous
manquait cruellement
c'est ce qu'ont cherché de de ce qu'on
voit actuellement à droite effectivement
on a pas forcément de mon point de vue
on n'a pas forcément ce leader
charismatique
actuellement visible identifiable
facilement mais au delà de ça c'est
aussi de mon point de vue le nécessaire
d'ouvrir de rassembler mais très large
de derrière une nouvelle droite c'était
le but de l'as de la création des de
l'ump à l'époque et ça se perd un peu je
pense qu'il faut revenir à cette idée là
qui avait eu jacques chirac à l'époque
pascal rapport à l'union on a moins la
culture du chef
et puis on se bouscule pas non plus
générale non on n'a plus la culture du
projet la culture des idées la culture
de la réflexion nous sommes profondément
ancré dans l'est dans les territoires un
chef n'a de sens que par rapport au
projet qu'il va porter
donc le débat principal c'est un débat
d'idées quelle ligne qu'est ce que l'on
veut pour la france qu'est ce que l'on
veut pour les français pour les
territoires je pense notamment la
ruralité
le débat doit être positionné ici
ensuite le chef y sortira naturellement
pour porter ces idées là mais dans un
premier temps au moins défendons les les
idées écrit ou un projet maxime thiébaut
votre ami un florian philippot lui s'est
fait une spécialité depuis plusieurs
années de seconde pour ses anniversaires
sur la tombe du général de gaulle je n'y
voyais pas parce que c'était un peu ce
que disait entre monsieur platret il ya
un instant on n'y voyait pas de problème
de paradoxes le général de gaulle ne
croyait ni en la droite ni en la gauche
disent être la droite et métro l'argent
et que la gauche n'était pas de gauche
et il avait une idée très simple de la
france c'est à dire de pouvoir
construire son avenir à partir du moment
cette dernière était libre de ses
actions et indépendante
si elle n'est plus aujourd'hui il avait
refusé une europe fédérale qui a été
acceptée depuis en fait la droite depuis
le traité d'amsterdam en 97 qui s'est
totalement soumis à l'union européenne
et qui a oublié de défendre ses intérêts
donc aujourd'hui une vraie politique
gaulliste c'est une politique où on
récupère réel pouvoir on rendrait à ce
peuple français qui se sent dépossédé la
plaine et distance afin qu'ils puissent
dessiner son avenir et dessiner une
industrie pour demain dessiner une belle
france c'est votre interprétation de la
vision gaulliste d'une droite nationale
on y reviendra sans doute si on parle un
petit peu d'europe gilles platret un
mois
de l'élection du président du parti des
républicains est-ce que trouver un
leader pour vous c'était essentiel on
viendra évidemment dans un instant aux
idées comme comme l'évoqué monsieur
rappaz mais est ce que est ce que
trouver un leader c'est essentiel pascal
grappin raison il faut absolument que le
débat d'idées qu'on va avoir d'ailleurs
dans un instant puissent vivre dans nos
familles politiques
donc là dessus il n'y a pas de sujet
simplement il faut aussi parce que les
choses sont ainsi faites dans un pays
comme le nôtre qu' il y ait de
l'incarnation
les idées ne sont pas simplement des
abstractions elles doivent être aussi
porter et une famille politique quelle
qu'elle soit doit avoir à la tête
quelqu'un qui puisse porter ses idées
mais ça veut pas dire que la personne
qui prend la tête d'une famille
politique doit négliger toutes les
sensibilités au sein de cette famille
très bien ça a toujours été le réel on
va dire c'est ne rien laisser l'ump si
c'est parfois une attente forte et elle
est manifeste chez nos militants et je
peux vous dire que le révoquer tout à
fait dans cet état d'esprit de respecter
les sensibilités qui s'expriment au
sénat ça c'est pas forcément
l'impression qu'il donne les noms c'est
pas l'impression que vous avez vous mais
je peux vous assurer que lui-même dans
l'exercice d'ailleurs de ses fonctions
régionales puisque à la tête de vernir
rhône alpes il est lui même l'homme du
rassemblement là quand même oublié il
est capable de ce rassemblement il a été
dans sa région et avec une belle
réussite un peu plus d'ailleurs que
notre pauvre bourgogne franche comté
avec la majorité que nous avons parce
que ça m'a certain nombre ici à penser
cette chose d rappelé que dans sa
majorité il y avait même au moins
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours des membres
du modem et qui aujourd'hui sont plutôt
avec monsieur macro et il sauf que il a
réussi à les rassembler sur la plate
forme de gouvernance de la région en
décembre 2015 donc c'est l'homme du
rassemblement et il le sera de la même
façon au sein des républicains si nous
parvenons avec lui a gagné d'élection
des 10 et 17 décembre
carisse quant à votre votre vision du
leader dont on vous parlait il ya un
instant quand vous évoquez l'ump
notamment il faut qu'il soit comment ce
leader
pour moi il faut qu'il soit il faut
qu'il soit ouvert qu'il soit novateur
qu'il soit à l'écouté des nouvelles
problématiques du pays est effectivement
qu'il travaille sur le débat d'idées et
je trouve que actuellement la campagne
la campagne sur les du prochain
président des républiques allemand que
manque effectivement de ce travail
autour du débat du débat d'idées alors
je sais que d'un autre côté le
secrétaire général bernard accoyer a
beaucoup travaillé dessus mais vraiment
pour moi le leader et il doit aussi nous
montrer ce la façon dont il va
travailler avec nous ensuite est ce
qu'il ya vraiment un débat parce que
certes il ya trois candidats et tout le
monde a droit de présenter ses idées
dans cette élection à terme mais il
semblerait quand même il ya un boulevard
qui va comme celui des caristes valérie
pécresse
oui c'est là c'est là le problème entre
guillemets de cette campagne c'est que
elle et elle est d'un intérêt à un peu
modérer parce qu'on s'est effectivement
qu'elle va être quel va être le résultat
au delà de ça et donc c'est pour ça que
tous ceux qui participent plus qu'ils
veulent plus travailler sur les idées
s'y intéressent peu et travaille déjà à
proposer les programmes pour les
prochaines pour les prochaines sessions
en fait vous êtes déjà sur le programme
mais vous vous êtes pas positionnez-vous
à titre personnel et l'équipe de valérie
pécresse sur un candidat parce que vous
estimez que ça vaut pas la peine
pour l'instant oui c'est vrai que j'y
réfléchis peut
je réfléchis peu à la présidence des
républicains est beaucoup plus à ce que
la droite va proposer aux aux électeurs
aux français pour les prochaines séances
pascal grappin agir oui simplement je
dirais il y a il y à débat au sein des
républicains aujourd'hui à lui dit je
dirais partenaires de des républicains
depuis un certain nombre d'années nous
regardons ce débat je crois qu'il faut
comprendre qu'il ya deux temps il ya un
temps de campagne où il ya des candidats
qui sont en campagne
et puis ensuite il y aura un homme ou
une femme qui sera élu et qui ont dos
sera le costume de président du
principal parti de la droite
républicaine l'on évoqué on peut dire
que je ne dis pas ça il est candidat il
me parle pas à moi aujourd'hui
il va l'être il parle à ses électeurs
et une fois qu'il sera élu s'il est élu
moi j'attends le résultat après il
endossera le costume de président du
principal parti de la droite
républicaine vous avez parlé vous voulez
télécharger vous tende la main y compris
sur les noms il sera dans un premier
temps obligé d'avoir un discours qui
rassemblera en interne chez eux en
interview et une fois bah oui parce que
on ne peut pas gagner si on n'est pas
rassemblé donc après il devra avoir et
je n'en doute pas un discours qui
permettra que une majorité se retrouve à
vous avez parlé de la droite de la
droite
moi je connais la droite républicaine je
connais le centre et je connais
l'extrême droite
je connais pas la droite de la droite je
sais pas ce que dupont aignan pour météo
extrême droite
moi si vous voulez ce qui au moment de
l'élection présidentielle
on l'appelait le thème allez hop a fait
le choix comme maxim power prime macron
sont pour moi des personnes d'extrême
droite alors la tête et pose la question
ne laurent wauquiez se pose la question
laurent wauquiez j'ai demandé à gilles
platret de vous répondre directement
laurent wauquiez est resté ambigu
entre les deux formes élection
présidentielle et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que lui reprochent beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui dans cette élection il a
laissé la liberté de vote
c'est conception démocratique sont pas
mises mettre en cause d'un autre côté je
voudrais éviter cette subtilité de
m'affronter avec pascal grappin parce
que je pense que pour être ensemble sur
les mêmes rangs à l'assemblée régionale
nous partageons un corpus de valeurs
telles que il sera difficile de nous
opposer
je pense en revanche que
l'interpellation que pascal grappin
vient de poser à l'endroit de maxim
thiébaut en particulier est une vraie
interpellation moi je suis désolé
effectivement il ya une droite
républicaine
nous sommes trois y appartenir et puis
il ya au delà une droite extrême extrême
droite qui a appelé à voter ouvertement
pour marine le pen il faut simplement
dire les choses c'est pas un c'est pas
un jugement de valeur à ce stade c'est
un constat que je pose et il faut quand
même que les choses soient dites vous
savez que beaucoup disent y compris à
l'extrême droite que si laurent wauquiez
était président des républicains il
pourrait y avoir des passerelles alors
on va laisser région que ça booste il
répondu à sa mairie pour quarante fois
il a répondu yakari pas enfin on peut
toujours le dire pendant des décennies
il a répondu 40 fois qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'accord parce qu'on ne peut pas y
avoir d'accord avec l'extrême droite
nous n'avons pas la même philosophie de
la vie tout simplement
et ça ça nous sépare irrévocablement 800
c'est terminé je l'aï réalisé
la ligne buisson n'était pas une ligne
d'accord électoral avec l'extrême droite
mais c'était au logis essentielle ment
conservatrice sur le plan sociétal mais
c'était pas une ligne de rapprochement
électorale
il n'y aura pas de rapprochement
électorale et vous savez pourquoi parce
que ça serait une offense faite à notre
propre système de valeurs une offense
faite à notre conception de l'homme et
ça serait ensuite un suicide politique
et lorsque le deal donnera alors maxime
thibon vous laisser répondre quand même
oui je vais répondre parce qu'en fait je
souris à entendre le vieux monde
discutait de la droite de l'extrême
droite de la gauche
on a eu un chamboulement politique
énorme cette année où le clivage
politique s'est redessiné entre d'un
côté les patriotes attachés à l'idée de
l'état nation et la démocratie nationale
et de l'autre les mondialistes qui sont
attachés au fait que les pouvoirs
doivent quitter la france et que
l'assemblée nationale le président de la
république le sénat l'ensemble des
institutions ne sont plus capables
aujourd'hui d'être
sponsable de l'avenir du pays et c'est
ça qui se passe donc moi ça me fait rire
l'histoire des springboks pas d'extrême
droite ça veut rien dire il faudrait
déjà arrivés à nous qualifier
moi je suis désolé je suis pas d serait
moins tu fondamentalement gaulliste j'ai
défendu toujours la démocratie nationale
je n'ai pas combattu les français en
2007 en faisant passer le traité de
lisbonne traité de lisbonne qui revenu
sur le traité constitutionnel de 2005 et
je suis désolé mais quand on fait un
coup de force par voie parlementaire
contre la voie référendaire du peuple
français
ça s'appelle une attitude qui n'est pas
démocratique maxime l'on évoqué il
pourrait vous séduire
mais laurent wauquiez on ne sait même
pas ce qu'ils pensent laurent wauquiez
laurent wauquiez c'est nacro en plus
identitaire c'est à dire que même
intervalle régulière mais non parce que
je suis pas identitaire regardez à l'axé
on a fait une charge de 26 engagement
les patriotes ou dans cette charte on
dit par exemple qu'on ne reviendra pas
sur le mariage pour tous parce qu'on
considère qu'il existe qu'il est
installé et il faut continuer c'est une
position qui est plutôt de gauche on a
des positions plutôt de droite sur la
méritocratie de bonnes positions de la
gauche on veut rassembler le meilleur de
la gauche
le meilleur de la droite à faire on vous
fait du mal oui parce que des maires et
nationales en défendant la souveraineté
nationale et ont fait pas de
l'identitaire parce que c'est ça la
réalité landes obligations laurent
wauquiez alors lorsque marion
maréchal-le pen je ne vois pas une
différence aujourd'hui dans l'eau je ne
vois pas une différence aujourd'hui
entre le routier marion maréchal-le pen
pourquoi je vais vous expliquer
rapidement
tout simplement parce que l'un comme
l'autre font de identitaire c'est à dire
qui ils nous parlent d'une france
fantasmé qui n'a jamais existé
parce qu'ils oublient une seule chose
c'est si on veut défendre l'identité du
pays
il faut être maître destin du pays et en
avoir l'attrait d'un mot parce que
j'aimerais qu'on en revienne aux idées
on a commencé là mais je vais faire
voilà je vais pas redire ce que j'ai
déjà dit les passerelles imaginaire qui
sont agités par certains parce que ça
les arrange bien sûr est juste relevé
quelque chose que vous avez dit vous
même
effectivement c'est du maquereau à
l'envers c'est à dire que il ya deux
blocs qui aujourd'hui nous disent donc à
côté le bloc au pouvoir et de l'autre
ceux blogs d'extrême droite qui dit pas
son nom qui dit la gauche et la droite
c'est dépassé la gauche et la droite
c'est dépassé moi je
pensons que la gauche et la droite c'est
pas dépasser nous pensons que ça reste
constitutif de notre vie politique
française et que ceux qui essayent de
nous dire ça ont des a priori et surtout
des arrière pensées qui les amène à
noyer le poisson pour essayer d'exister
nous nous pensons que ce débat doit
exister une droite qui ne soit pas
recroquevillée sur elle-même et élargie
sur le centre c'est une évidence enfin
voila je le redis à l'endroit pascal
grappin mais ça y est c'est très bien ce
que ce que je poursuivais quelques
doutes encore mais non ça mais je dis
s'y plaît dites que vous avez vous même
soulevé à un moment donné c'est naturel
qui a un dialogue entre la droite et le
centre républicain le centre-droit ça me
paraît logique et même constitutif de ce
que nous pouvons demain pour poser aux
français mais simplement il ya deux
attitudes la droite la gauche n'existe
pas on sait très bien qui dit ça il y en
a d'autres qui disent que ça existe et
nous nous voulons exister à rejeter dans
celui d'un sinistre qui ceux qui disent
que la droite et la gauche ça n'existe
plus vraiment il ya le président de la
république emmanuel macron qui fait tout
pour laisser relativement peu de place à
la droite notamment mais au parti
socialiste
aussi est ce qu'il reste encore un
espace caris quentin entre marine le pen
et emmanuel macron pour vous aider les
dernières échéances ont quand même
montré qu'il ya un certain ya un grand
nombre d'électeurs qui ne se sont pas
reconnus dans la politique macro je
voudrais d'ailleurs revenir au début sur
votre vos propos introductif l'échec
cuisant de françois fillon
vu la campagne qui est des
présidentielles qui était mené il est du
soleil dans la droite n'était pas au
second tour d'élection présidentielle
puis de voix à bedoin s'acquiert qu'avec
l'arrivée l'agrandir là c'est pour ça
que j'ai tâché cuisant c'est une analyse
vue là la campagne qui a été menée je me
dis que s'il y avait encore prise et
nous allons amener aussi oui mais il y
avait encore des électeurs de droite je
ne sais j'étais fillonniste donc voila
voila mais donc il reste la place
largement pour pour effectivement un
mouvement rassembleur
de droite entre l'extrême droite et le
le positionnant macron personne à droite
ne se reconnaît dans la fiscalité dans
la campe dans le dans le gouvernement
macron et ces mesures fiscales
elle doit être vue rigole mais menwar
philippe vous avez lu le programme dans
ce sillon ça c'est pas parce que c'est
toi qui j'ai très bien des contrats
aidés
les élus de droite marie claude jarrot
maire de montceau les mines qui
aujourd'hui s'indigne sur les contrats
aidés alors qu'elle a soutenu monsieur
fillon était pour sa suppression il est
important de préciser dans la loi
travail la loi antiterroriste l'affairé
de liettres fc pas de programme et de la
droite la loi travail ce qui est la même
que nous fait dit que c'est la droite
c'est la csg on n'est pas d'accord sur
la loi travail c'était globalement 95% à
copier coller on est d'accord mais on a
droit aussi et je pense que c'est ce que
les thèmes de la mort des manuels ma
croix sur gouvernement nombre ne pas
vous laisser les clivages aussi on a le
droit de dire qu'un gouvernement qui
n'est pas de notre tendance prend des
positions qui sont les mêmes que les
nôtres et coupe et qu'on aurait pu voter
moi je l'avais dit prendre la campagne
des législatives effectivement la loi
travail c'est quelque chose que j'aurais
pu voter
on doit aussi arrêter ce clivage et
s'opposer systématiquement à ce que
c'est la pollution c'est la position de
l'ue et notamment à travers les
constructif
pascal grappa vous dit pas oui la loi
travail la loi antiterroriste les sf on
vote
moi je reviens sur ce que dit clarisse
content il s'est quand même passé dans
cette campagne présidentielle quelque
chose que nous n'avions jamais vu dans
notre dans d'autres pays si toutes ces
affaires n'étaient pas sorties ou 6 et
moi je dirai où on en est aujourd'hui où
on en est aujourd'hui dans ses affaires
il va peut-être falloir attendre quand
même à un moment donné la décision des
juges parce que vous voulez faire
revenir françois fillon n'ont jamais les
blanchit non c'est parce que je dis vos
amis longwy et je crois mais je crois
que dans l'analyse politique
oublier ce qui s'est passé c'est le
passé à autre chose que la lumière soit
faite et bien sûr ce qui s'est passé
parce que vous savez je ne va pas faire
du complotisme aujourd'hui mais tout ça
est tombée très opportunément pour
disqualifier le candidat de la droite
républicaine et poussé à notre candidat
qui est aujourd'hui à l'elysée voilà
qu'il faut juste qu'on regarde les
choses lui sion est ce que dit pascal
grappin et et je pense que c'est clair
c'est que françois fillon malgré cette
campagne qui est inédite dans l'histoire
la démocratie française perd la
qualification deuxième tour 2 1 et demi
pour cent c'est comme ça il fait partie
sur la sécurité sociale s'était pas
terminé parce que j'ai j'ai pas terminée
je rejoins pleinement ce que dit j
attendais mais qu'est ce que cela veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il ya un big bang
complet et puis qu'on a aujourd'hui un
président de la république qui
effectivement fait un petit coup l'un
petitcollin petit colin la kids et à
déstabiliser complètement le paysage le
paysage politique mais bon il ya eu des
sénatoriales dernièrement j'ai
l'impression que le paysage politique
il s'est re stabiliser quand on regarde
le résultat d'essai avant de
déstabiliser le sénat oui oui mais faut
pas oublier que le sénat c'est quoi
c'est quand même
les sénateurs sont des représentants des
communes c'est la vie elle est où elle
est bien dans les communes nos
concitoyens ils habitent ou dans les
communes donc ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que il y aura un laps de temps où
tout va se reconstruire un laps de temps
nécessaire et ont tous des cas moi ce
que je crois c'est que il faut pendant
au moins un certain temps que l'on
arrive à avoir des majorités d'idées
pour qu'on puisse retravailler et avoir
vraiment un programme après pour la
france pour faire gagner la france
mais on doit se retrouver sur des
majorités d'idées on se retrouve sur la
loi travail
c'est une évidence et puis elle est
votée sur la suppression du sf je veux
bien qu'on en cause deux secondes on s'y
retrouve mais partiellement que l'on
impose quelqu'un qui a un appartement
puis qu'on n'impose pas celui qu à des
lingots d'or moi ça me choque ça me
choque donc là on ne se retrouve que
partiellement la ch
petit point la csg moi je veux bien
qu'on supprime mais finalement ce que
c'est c'est une augmentation de la
fiscalité
puisqu'on élargi on augmente vos places
une cg sur un une basque est beaucoup
plus élargie
donc on augmente la fiscalité et on
augmente la fiscalité en direction de
qui des retraités
allez leur demander maintenant si on
leur avait expliqué sa c6 csg platret
macro est un manoeuvrier emmanuel macron
qui s'en sort qui les a ni droite ni
gauche n'a jamais autant penser comme
chef de l'état car aucun de ses
prédécesseurs à la droite et la gauche
il est l'oeuvre de destruction de la
droite républicaine à commencer mon de
la campagne électorale avec eux ce qu'on
s'est dit tout à l'heure sur ce qui
s'est passé autour de françois fillon
elle continue aujourd'hui avec la
nomination d'edouard philippe de
darmanin et la certain nombre d'autres
comme le maire pour essayer de faire
exploser ce parti lorsque nous serons là
reposer n'avait pas tenté non attendez
le parti socialiste était respectée en
tant que parti socialiste là il ya une
volonté de destruction
or ce qui est en train de se passer avec
cette élection interne avec ce débat
d'idées qui se développent et moi je
suis heureux voilà que valérie pécresse
ait lancé son mouvement parce que on a
besoin de brasser ses idées assez
quelqu'un pour laquelle j'ai fait
énormément des cimes
donc moi j'ai pas de difficulté à ce que
la famille vivent dans ses composantes
et ses sensibilités
mais simplement on est en train de la
reconstituer et ça c'est la plus belle
leçon qu'on puisse opposer à monsieur
macron non la droite républicaine n'est
pas morte malgré tous vos efforts elle
va continuer de se relever et demain
elle pourra avec le centre proposer
quelque chose de valable conforme à ses
idées et à son corpus idéologique aux
françaises et aux français je vais
laisser réagir maxime thébaux mais avant
je vais vous laisser avec cette phrase
de bernard cazeneuve le ministre
l'ancien premier ministre qui dans un
récent entretien au monde disait que ni
droite ni gauche cet être de droite
réflexion aujourd'hui la le paysage
politique s'est recomposé et moi j'ai
été stupéfait pendant ce débat de voir
la manière avec laquelle vous avez voulu
retirer finalement à revenir aux vieux
monde vieux parti figé qui sont
totalement dépassées aujourd'hui vous
avez trois dynamique vous avez les
marcheurs qui ont leur idée vous avez
les insoumis qui ont leur projet
politique mais tu aussi leurs problèmes
je pense m à la mode
noé d'autres et vous avez les patriotes
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
une vie politique qui est lancée sur une
dynamique où vous avez d'un côté les
mondialistes je suis désuni au fonds
national de gestion jean françois copé
je me dis que je me suis battu tout seul
le reconnaissez le canton le même
programme que monsieur macro vous ne
savez pas comment c'est à dire nationale
oui je vous intéresse plus vous savez ce
lundi julien aubert julien aubert était
le seul god is candidate et aurait pu
être candidat et finalement le parti a
verrouillé
julien aubert disait laurent wauquiez se
trompe il fait de l'identitaire parce
qu'ils oublient défendre la souveraineté
nationale et donc ils oublient que c'est
l'identité de la france qu'il faut c'est
l'offre nationale vous avez oublié dans
sa nos fonds national paraît totalement
oublié la souveraineté nationale est en
train de devenir un parti qui se limite
sur l'islam radical et l'immigration de
masse finalement il devient partir ou
fédéraliste libéral qui ressemble de
plus en plus je suis dans ce qu'ils
avaient la parole christian non
rationnel que vous avez quitté il ya
quelques semaines
00h02 émission est bien plus maxime qui
est beau je vais vous demander à tous de
réagir
quel est le programme qu'il faut selon
vous pour la droite aujourd'hui pour
exister à vous à la france pourra sont
les meilleurs de la droite et de la
gauche retrouvé notre souveraineté
nationale
être maître de notre destin afin de
sauver nos classes moyennes qui pendant
tous ces rebelles et ses belles
logorrhée sont en train de souffrir à ce
qu'elles grimpent à même question quel
est le programme qu'il faut pour
permettre à la droite d'exister je vous
le disais depuis 2007 émissions entre
marine le pen emmanuel macron il faut
qu'on continue à travailler parce
qu'aujourd'hui un programme c'est pas
quelque chose qui sort en claquant des
doigts
il faut partir de la base c'est à dire
qu'il faut partir de ce qui se fait dans
nos 36000 communes parce que c'est là
que le travail se fait c'est là que les
gens vivent ces lacs sont les élus
s'appuyer sur cette base là pour
construire un programme mais bien
évidemment dans un cadre profondément
européen dans un cadre profondément
libérale et sociale et dans un cadre où
le respect des questions quelques
secondes à quelques secondes il faut
défendre des classes moyennes je crois
que ces zones le grand objectif qui est
nôtre aujourd'hui parce que ce sont les
grands oubliés de ce quinquennat des
commence il faut défendre la culture
française parce que elle aussi est
malmené par monsieur macro
ils en feront vraiment les défenseurs
caresse quentin dix bombes oui pareil il
faut il faut n'oublions pas que nous
nous chez avec valérie pecresse nous
allons travailler avec les élus de
terrain pour remonter les un programme
correspondant à tous les français merci
à tous les cas d'avoir participé à ce
débat un débat qui se prolonge avec la
partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
laurent wauquiez président de la région
voisine et candidat à la présidence des
républicains après l'info régionale bon
dimanche
[Musique]